now one of the reasons that apps have
often failed is that they didn't respond
well to the target audience all of the
audiences you might be presenting two
are going to be well aware of that fact
and so it will be an asset to you to
present evidence from your user research
this is secondary reason we've been
saving all of it it allows us to show
direct quotations in text audio or video
from users if you can show that your
prototype is changed in response to user
feedback you can show that you're least
willing to adapt to the market which is
key to having your app be successful
across a more diverse customer group
later on what this looks like is largely
up to you but there are some big no nose
don't focus on all the ways in which
you've gotten it wrong instead make it
clear these are ways your app has gotten
better over time also try not to show
too many responses from the same user
it's very easy to focus on the most
eloquent user in each test but if you do
you'll be building an app for that user
in particular rather than your target
market generally with as many
prototyping iterations as you've been
doing you should have a wide range of
users who have discussed your app